foreign
the three Muslims today we're going to
be talking about the importance of dark
chocolate specifically 90 black we don't
do anything less than that Bismillah how
are you guys doing pretty good
so Rami do you want to take it away uh I
despise dark chocolate I don't know this
guy likes white chocolate that's a very
atrocious thing no give me this bro you
don't even deserve sponsored by anyone
and you can have your chocolate better
we belong to only Allah yes with that
being said today's episode is on the
importance of Salah
specifically importance of taking your
time with Salah this is something that I
wasn't too familiar with because around
me just looking at Muslims you know
growing up when I went to the Masjid
everyone was doing the turbo prayer have
you heard about that yeah it's kind of
like you know before on her and y'all
about to get the meme in a bit before
Angel even does a lot of work but
everyone's already done this a lot I
used to think
I used to think truth be told that
Arnold really likes to go a little slow
like a grandpa you know take his time
but I tried doing this myself and I
realized bro the amount of presence that
I feel
is mashallah and I think none other than
on house should uh take it away and give
us a little bit of his revert journey
and how praying slowly has succeeded you
inshallah
so
I mean I don't really
know the fast version I never did it
you know like I always knew that like
okay I just want to take my time with it
um I remember when I first started
learning how to do the prayer I was
watching this one video on YouTube where
I don't know which one it is but I mean
I love listen they they didn't go fast
but they didn't go slow they win at like
a midpoint and I'm all just kind of
following along
and trying to understand like the
movements and like when to say what
right and um when I was doing this even
then I was like this is a little too
fast for me like I feel like I kind of
want to slow it down I think this just
comes back to that mindfulness that just
like being aware of like what you're
doing
um really trying to get as deep into it
as possible pause and um when I meditate
I like to take my time you know and I I
figured okay well when I pray let me let
me take my time let me see what happens
with this and I saw that
I felt very present during the prayer
um it was very easy to go deep into the
player to where it's like
when I'm making Dubai it feels very
sincere like it's very genuine you know
and
um
I don't know man like a lot of people
would be like oh like how are you
um I I don't even want to say it because
like I don't see it myself
um they'll say like how do you how do
you you know take so long how are you so
present in the prayer and stuff I'm just
like just slow down
that's it like I didn't do anything
special I just slowed down
so I I don't think if I if I requested
you during Salah one day to just pray
super fast
let's say double if not triple the pace
that you do how would that make you feel
during this Allah
aside from rushed aside from rush I
would just feel like I'm
going through the motion not even
connecting not only I'm not even giving
myself the time to connect like
sometimes I go into praying my mind's
like all over the place and it's like
it'll take me like a good 15-20 minutes
of being in the prayer of being in
prostration for a very long time before
I start like
getting to a point where my mind starts
to calm down and I'm getting more in
tune with the prayer
um get into that bro the connection
thing because Salah linguistically means
connection connection and how many
people are out here just lacking the
connection they look at Salah as an
obligation which it is nonetheless we're
not trying to negate that but they look
at it as just something to cross on the
to-do list you know it's just a chore
stuck for Allah but what do you what do
you mean when you say connection oh
first off let me say like I don't always
feel the connection
and I don't always get like super deep
into prayer I think that's like human
it's human but it's um it's a
misconception that people might you know
y'all might
feel like that oh take the time in the
prayer more presently it's not always
going to be like that
um
what was the question again
what do you mean by the connection
connection you know because a lot of
people think Salah is just
motions
ibada act of worship obligation yeah
they don't understand the the reflective
or connective spiritual yeah okay I got
the perfect example for y'all so think
about like a very tough point in your
life
and in this tough point
that's when you start praying the most
that's when you start doing actually
bother the most that's when you spend
the most time in the prayer whereas like
the deepest you'll ever go in your
prayers is during this time when like
things are going like the worst as
possible for you
uh that's the connection that I'm
talking about because in that state you
feel like you were being as sincere as
possible and it's like you you'll be
praying and you'll be so in tune with it
you'll even feel like
random emotions coming up like you'll
start crying out of nowhere and stuff
like this like where does this come from
it comes none other than connecting with
Allah
and um
again like I'm making the the example to
show you like okay this is what happens
when you got the lowest point in your
life
Allah puts you in a state of submission
so in order to feel that connection with
Allah you have to be in a state of
submission
and I feel like when you're rushing
through the prayer you're going through
it very fastly you're not in the state
of submission you're not you know I mean
I'm speaking for myself and I may be
wrong right like there may be people out
here who do
you know they pray fast and they do
connect with Allah like I can't say that
is the truth it's hard though I agree
with you because when I try to pray fast
it bro
there's there's a level of
gratitude that we have towards Allah for
even giving us signs when we're not on
point with our Islam the kid doesn't
always that right think about it so
we're completely indebted to that bro
and one of the things is when I'm
praying Timely not just punctual but I
take my time with my Salah everything in
my life is kind of just smooth you know
what I mean there's times where I'm
rushing through Salah and I feel like
the days are just passing by I don't
have enough time in my hands you know
trade work family everything's just you
know and the day is done I'm like oh
what the hell you know it's already
Friday again you know but there's times
when I'm taking my time with Salah and
bro I feel like I have so much time and
space with the day you know what I mean
it sounds weird because logically you
would think that if you spend more time
with Salah you have less time during the
day but what's weird is actually when
you spend more time with Salah you have
more time in the day you just get better
with like just being in a flow State as
a person reminds me of the same that I
heard I don't remember which video I
think we're watching this video together
but they were saying like if you want
success in the Dunya
it's in the prayer yeah you want Power
it's in the prayer like if you want
financial success in the prayer if you
want love it's in the prayer like
everything comes from the prayer so like
the more in tune you are in your Salah
the more everything else is kind of like
unravels for you like the Dunya
literally comes to your feet and like
the best example that I can give to this
is when I was in Thailand when I was in
Thailand I was literally going to the
Masjid every single prayer mashallah bro
and I was literally
in Thailand they have this thing known
as Sabai Sabai is like the lifestyle
it's basically like laid back like chill
too right like Hakuna Matata yeah like I
guess I never heard about it and I've
only heard of it in the Disney movie I
don't know okay you know Africa wherever
you go you tell anyone anything why are
you not stressed why everyone's just
like no stress are you talking about the
um the Hawaiian one which song
I don't know it sounds similar
Ohana means family I don't know maybe
I'm getting a mixed
the wrong page damn bro
this uh we're returning this tomorrow so
what I'm saying in Thailand they have
the signal Supply so it's all like
children relax Costa Rica Pura Vida all
this stuff right so in in Thailand I was
I toned it down because like over here
in the US I'm just like go go go go like
okay I got this I got that I got this
coaching session I got to record this I
gotta talk over here I gotta call my
parents and all this stuff is like just
stacking on top where it's like even if
I make time for my prayer
it wasn't the same as Thailand like in
Thailand bro
I think in total one day I spent
uh maybe like four or five hours in
prayer not at once but like spread out
you know like the five prayers the
Sunnah prayers the night prayers like
bro all this stuff and it's again this
is not to boast
but it's like it's to say like the
difference of like when you actually
take your time with it and bro when I
took my time with it and I I had took in
I had spent a total of like
what did I say it was like three five
hours three to five hours bro like it
honestly felt like time was almost like
still like time was not moving like yes
it was getting darker or brighter but
time just did not exist in this moment
bro it's such a beautiful you ever felt
that bro yeah listen when I was in Saudi
living the Medina lifestyle with the
Makkah lifestyle
bro
I want everyone to understand that all
we were doing is just waking up having
breakfast at the hotel right or not
waking up going to the Masjid for Fajr
going to the Haram coming back having
breakfast maybe sleeping napping a
little bit after that going to uh you
know
Salah coming back going to Asar Salah
coming back going to Maghrib Salah
coming back maybe dinner after that
going to Aisha Salah coming back
maybe a couple Tawas here and there on
the Kaaba
I didn't work
I didn't have school I didn't do
anything bro I was exhausted anyone that
has been to amra or Hajj can attest to
this all I was doing is just prayer but
my entire life and my day revolved
around Salah and bro it was crazy how
fast time would fly by that when I was
there I was just like bro if someone
told me to like work full-time I was
like how would I squeeze this into my
schedule because here
five minutes five minutes after five
minutes five minutes Isha five minutes
25 minutes a day bro there was the whole
experience bro taking your time going to
the Masjid every footstep I would feel
the Baraka once you enter the mosque you
know give some sataka if you want you
know talk to some people you know go sit
down reflect pick up a Quran you know
read a little bit you know Salah starts
take your time do the summer after that
after that they had janaza prayer very
frequently there after every Salah
mostly you know which is a funeral
prayer and bro before you know it you
would spend a total of like two three
four hours per day prayer like what you
were saying
and those days I didn't feel incomplete
but when I look at it now praying 25
minutes total per day day's done I'm
just like oh I could have just done this
more I could have done that more I could
have made more money or you know what I
mean
but my my spirituality is just hungry
bro but over there wasn't you know
and most of all best of all it was free
bro
everything was free well of course who
doesn't know that but yeah yeah it's
crazy bro so I think
something that is very crazy
is that we know this we know that in the
prayer that's where the success is
that's where everything is
but when you try to take your time
during the prayer like things will arise
like maybe you have allergies maybe
you're sick maybe you have a headache
maybe your neck is hurting maybe your
knees are hurting like things will arise
and like of course you you
you do what you have to but the doing
the prayer right so like you're taking
the time it's like you don't want to
take the time because it's like oh man I
got this going on I have that I have
allergies um it's a little tough for me
right now but if you do take the time
you notice the effects for yourself now
not on top of that then you have the
swim improves like I I thought about
this a while back and I told this to
many people and they're like yeah you
know like this has actually been spoken
about by a lot of the sheikhs and that
is that um
the prayer like the Father the prayer is
like it basically opens the door and
then the Sunnah prayer is like you
stepping through the door and what is
this door it's like it's peace it's
Tranquility it's like that true
fulfillment that we're looking for here
you know and
um
yeah we we often think like we don't
have the time for it or like say no I
don't want to do it it's like extra it's
like okay well if I take my time in the
normal period let's say I took 20
minutes like do I really want to take
another 20 minutes to hit so no
but it's like dude
what's your feeling in your head where
you're like oh no I don't know if I want
to do this right now
if you can
what are you doing bro bro I have to
take a picture of this setup just so
just so like yo editor zoom in on this
bro like why would I not laugh this is
what I'm looking at bro just zoom in on
that stuff I need to give you like my
man has one mic bro look at this
that's what I'm seeing bro
so yeah it's like your mind will make it
seem like you don't want to do it but
it's like deep down you know that that's
what you have to do it's almost like
when when you want to be successful it's
like the thing that you don't want to do
is like the thing that you have to do
yeah right so it's like oh you want to
have like that connection with Allah you
want to be at peace you want to have
um
I don't know you just want to be in tune
with everything yeah yeah you just gotta
spend the time in the prayer but you
know exactly what you got to do similar
to what you said the analogy that the
Sheikh has made right I heard this thing
in my you know just just around I don't
know if this is actually like
islamically valid or not but they say
that the Salah is for Allah
right it's it's specifically just
worship it's not to get anything nothing
right
and then the Sunnah is you know where
you kind of start to like make some Dua
for you if you want to like this is
where you know you can make a lot of Dua
and then the no waffle prayer like the
extra extra prayer you know that's like
when you can like it just it just shows
like
it changes the frame into like seeking
something from Allah to like okay no
this is ibada this is worship not just
prayer and then eventually it's like
okay cool you know even when we make Dua
and sujud
do we only just make the wall right away
do we
we see Savannah three times then we make
the Dua or we should right so now Rami
you've been awfully quiet bro yeah I was
gonna ask you about like because I know
you suffer with allergies so like what
do you do to be able to reach that that
state of connection when you can't stay
in this you know that prostrated
position for like 20 30 40 minutes
because the allergies acting up yeah
then I I don't
if I can't but what do you do aside from
that you spend more time in the Dua like
yeah yeah so usually being in sujud
versus being just and standing in prayer
even with my with me personally runny
nose it doesn't it doesn't change with
what position I'm in it's more so if I
have a runny nose bro it ruins
everything I can't stand in Roku I can't
be in sujud I can't stand in my in the
standing up in the raka I can't if my
nose is going so I just take a tissue I
keep in my pocket or a few and I just
keep my pocket if I need to I'll wipe or
whatever and just keep going
um but uh I don't suffer with allergies
too much I understand I think for most
people like it'll come and go but
they'll always have moments where
they're ham did that and you know
actually side note realizing those
moments of when you have a good is what
really counts because when you have a
body like oh I remember when I had it
good right so flip it initially it'll be
a lot more grateful inshallah but
um I do want to talk about just kind of
add another layer to what you guys are
saying there's with me personally
there's no or almost something with
knowing I'm taking time that makes it
more important it makes it easier to
want to take that time it makes it
easier to focus right because
I kind of have two states when I'm
praying one state is like I'm just
praying normally how I usually pray
normal speed and because you know Surah
Fatiha is Flowing I know exactly what it
means and I have the like the the kind
of I don't want to say translation but
the meaning flowing my head when I'm
reading it
when I you know slow it down and really
focus that's something my teacher taught
me like especially like during a show
during night to focus on every syllable
even if you're reading slowly like
alhamdulillah
people probably got impatient just
waiting for me to finish that Ayah right
but if you're studying like that in
prayer you're really focusing on every
syllable you're going slowly that is the
most tranquil you will feel in your life
and if you put into perspective we
talked about what Salah means and you
know how it means to connect and so on
and so forth you can also add that it
was given to the process of them
directly from Allah on the night Journey
but something that's overlooked a lot
is before the five daily Salah was made
obligatory what was obligatory for the
Muslims
yes but in terms of praying for the five
daily Salah was obligatory right praying
at night yeah praying at night was
obligatory night prayer before the five
night prayer was obligatory they had to
stay up all night praying and I know you
remember this my teacher is telling us
right that they were they were so tired
they would have to literally tie
something under their armpits to keep
them standing so they don't fall over
and some people would fall over in the
middle of Salah because you know
especially during my prayer who take his
time he would pray very slow and my
teacher I don't know the sources for
this my teacher even mentioned like you
know like maybe even like 20 30 minutes
maybe more and just in one Roku just
bowing it's like imagine just bowing for
20 30 minutes you know it's a workout in
and of itself at night after a long day
working in the heat you know maybe even
fasting
well I don't think the fasting and then
that's a lot of the nighttime obligatory
at the same time but he would still pre
Knight prayer after no when it wasn't
obligatory you know
that you know spent Allah is tiring but
that builds character and obviously
Allah doesn't do anything randomly
always those things you know for a
reason so if you look at the jikma
behind it we try and attribute some kind
of wisdom behind it you could say like
it strengthened the Muslims it granted
them this kind of you know assurance and
it really you know if you think about
also it weeded out the people that were
maybe were too weak to actually practice
Islam because some people actually left
Islam because of that they were still
practicing because they couldn't handle
it and the ones that are stuck the ones
that stuck to it
[Music]
right at the beginning
right at the beginning now you know
after Islam has been established in the
Sharia and everything and you know right
at the beginning and only after that did
he abrogate it and give the five daily
Salah and that's the thing bro this is
something that's like it's crucial and
after the childhood like bare minimum to
just be a Muslim right the shahada first
most important thing you do after the
Salah
then you have you know Ramadan and all
that there's a God and you know
Hajj and all that but it really goes to
show because think about it your shahada
is something that's kind of like it's
not a one-time thing you're constantly
in the state where you believe in the
shahada
Salah is a little less frequent so to
say you know it's it's like minimum five
times a day then you have Ramadan which
is once a year but it's 30 days then you
have and you can fast other times if you
want to then you got zakat which is just
one time a year now and then Hajj
minimum inshallah if you can once in
your lifetime right
I was also going to ask you guys a
question
um I want to know what you guys think
but us being born into I don't want to
say non-muslim families right because me
and you were born Muslim
an unhose a river masha'allah but we
were all at least even if we weren't
born into Arab families we didn't speak
Arabic growing up yeah and we still
don't speak here but we're not native
Arabic speakers forget even fluently but
we probably know like I live about that
like basic stuff like you know we know
basic meanings but
do you guys think that native Arabic
speakers or those that are fluent in
Arabic have an advantage over us
in understanding Quran or during Salah
like they just because it's already
their language they can feel that
connection easier I'm not saying it's an
excuse for us not to learn Arabic but do
you think they have that Advantage yeah
yeah 100 have that Advantage if you ask
someone you know who has better genetics
than someone who has worse than us who
has an advantage physically obviously
they want to be better genetics same
thing here if someone can speak Arabic
fluently they will have an event what
they don't have right they have the
advantage of being able to understand
and read and write all that stuff they
don't have the advantage in the reward
because a person who struggles to recite
or struggles to learn they get double
the reward
um never even thought of it that way bro
and it's also too like
yeah they might understand it better
right
and this is where I'm gonna say
something that you probably oh I forgot
this was here
I'm gonna say something that you know
it's like what you were telling me that
I keep saying over and over and over
again
but um
followers
for lower is like you could have the
person who doesn't speak Arabic and it's
gonna hit them more
you know like they'll listen to the
recitation and it actually pierces
through the veil and hits their heart
more than it would the person who can
actually
rationally and logically understand it
up here but it doesn't Pierce the Veil
down here
she left him bro I'm gonna give you a
humble request to please move the mic
from where it is
not that one bro this is this guy
bruh literally bro I was looking for
that one but aside from that um before
we move on to the next topic I did have
another question for y'all inshallah
for on how it was done
are you giving it to me bro
I have two mics now I don't know what
I'm gonna do with two mics but you just
put it on the back like in display just
have it standing
twist it around
there you go
I see no problem
[Laughter]
so my my question that I wanted to ask I
can't remember it
bro I stuck for a lot bro honor such a
serious episode too bro
why you take the top off bro give me the
tip
uh
no just put it away bro let's put that
thing bro
foreign
okay my next question before you move on
to that is
some people
are not as fortunate to be in a position
where they can take time away from Salah
should they that's a different story I'm
not talking about that
but let's say they work a job that's
extremely demanding you know let's say
their boss doesn't let them pray of
course of course we know we shouldn't
take jobs that get in the way of our
dean of course but let's say you're like
a single parent you know you got to
provide this is just what this is the
situation you're given we know where we
should be as Muslims but this is just a
situation these are the cards you adult
and can you do something about it of
course but let's say at that moment they
haven't yet so they're working a job
they can't or you know they're they're
in school back to back let's say they're
like a surgeon you know they have
back-to-back patients anything I'm just
I'm trying to play Devil's Advocate and
there's no way for them to take time out
maybe they can just squeeze in like
quick like four minutes a lot of five
minutes so that's it they can't take
more time right or stuff like that they
have to delay it so what do you what do
you say to these brothers and sisters
that are in that predicament the times
where you can pray Make It Count so like
if they're at work and they only have
like four or five minutes okay like do
the prayer at that speed that you need
to do it right but then when you go home
and then you got time
take your time
I mean that's that's the best that I
could give
yeah
um
take your breaks wisely you can a lot of
time you can choose when you go on break
uh very few people are actually told
when to go on break right so if you can
go on break at a good time even if you
have to be kind of smart about it I'm
not saying you should do this but let's
say you know
and so also starts at four o'clock you
have a half an hour long break right you
can go at like 3 45 or whatever
and then four o'clock hits is also a
song Break you can pray also and then
boom that's two pairs within the span 30
minutes so I'm not saying be technical
like that
um if you have multiple breaks which
people work long hours usually have
three breaks or so um or a minimum two
spam them out
so you can hit your solo just make sure
it's your priority right your your first
priority is to pray and then to work and
if you know your boss is not it depends
on where you are in the world right if
your boss not gonna respect that you can
complain and at least in Canada you have
a religious freedom you have a religious
right and they can't stop you from a
religious obligation when I work at
Superstore I've actually had a full
prayer room and I literally called the
manager at the time up and be like you
know hey I have to pray and no questions
asked okay come get my key I'll take the
kid from and go pray give them the key
back go back to work literally five
minutes and they wouldn't even really
knock time off of my clock
well and these people who are at jobs
where they just really don't even have
the time to pray
or they should be looking into something
else yeah and like a lot of them will be
like oh but I need the money I need this
listen you leave something for the sake
of Allah
and it's replaced by something better
you know what's in the Quran Allah
literally says in the Quran that those
that leave Haram
just you know those that that let go
from they don't submit to Haram just to
get money the provisioning is is coming
to them sooner or later it's already
written inshallah so there's no excuse
there's a lot of people you know I feel
exactly what you guys are going through
that you're in jobs with his music or
there's you know non-maharam women just
wearing whatever shout out to the
personal trainers bro get out of that
situation uh you're working in jobs
where you can't pray or you're afraid to
pray or you're working with a bunch of
kofar not just non-muslims bro but
people that are like anti-islam
I feel LeBron it's tough but at the end
of the day when it's all said and done
on the day of judgment what's going to
weigh heavy on the skills bro
oh Allah I please the masses
I I didn't show them how Muslim I am and
scare them off or did you pray
and that's why I believe
gradualism is key right so those are
already in that predicament yes slowly
no show them that you're praying slowly
like you know just be okay with it and
and don't be authentic you know take
time off you don't want to pray in front
of them be like okay I'm just gonna go
to that room that small room I'm just
gonna pray five minutes later you come
back people are going for smoke breaks
hours in a day anyway and then you come
back Friday oh I gotta take this little
off I'll end later you know if I can go
to Jama prayer it's obligatory for me oh
but we have uh Abdul over there he
doesn't pray God yeah you know and you
saw the slope but for the people that
can't that that are not in it yet they
haven't started it yet establish it from
day one these are one of these
boundaries if you want to work at a
corporate job or anywhere like that it
has to be there from day one there's no
like slowly islamicize them no show them
this is your identity this is what you
got to do this is what you're about from
day one and if I can't do this I can't
practice My Religion which is actually
going against corporate a lot today so
you everyone has the ability to practice
their religion then I can't work and
never sacrifice your in for money ever
it's never a worthy trade-off bro yeah
100 percent
one
hundred
percent Hondo Hondo p with that being
said bro my next thing that I wanted to
double a little deeper on once I
surrounded this question
um being a born Muslim right how was
your relationship with Salah growing up
you know it was absent bro okay maybe I
shouldn't say that stuff no I know but
it wasn't really there unfortunately you
know we'd go to eat Salah once like
twice a year
that's literally it
it's allowed like you know even drama if
any you know we had in school it was
lucky but that's kind of it you know and
when you first started praying Salah
you're getting on Dean coming back to
Allah what really changed what things
did you notice bro and everything
everything changed like I literally
everything changed it would be
undermining really trying to explain one
or two things especially when it comes
to Salah you know it's just that
the the there's different levels really
there's the consistency and discipline
but there's also the spiritual side the
the contentment the peace tranquility
and all that stuff that you know you can
bring into your life you know there's
nothing better than even like praying
under the stairs in school and getting
in a Catholic school too
yeah that's true we are praying on the
stairs just getting back to it and going
seeing all these Catholic people who
half of them don't even really practice
the religion you know I'm being the
Muslim there and being confident I'm a
Muslim you know I'm brave enough to pray
under the stairs and that's not like a
crazy thing like oh I'm fighting a war
or anything any but some people you know
difficult for them so there's that that
you know proud aspect of that pride in
being a Muslim
I think one thing that people need to
get in check and maybe maybe Idaho can
get into this because you came from a
non-muslim upbringing and you saw how
Muslims were portrayed but there is a an
era of embarrassment that people possess
being Muslim
and what I mean by that is they do
things that are unislamic to fit in
they sacrifice Dean just to be included
just to get approval validation
have you experienced this yourself you
don't need to hear your own thing but
have you noticed this with Muslims bro
being being a non-muslim at one point
coming into Islam reverting to Islam
have you ever felt this type of
embarrassment bro do you see this in
people
um I see it in some people
uh but for myself
like I definitely had moments in the
beginning
well I was just kind of like not telling
people yeah we're not not really one uh
Act
like a Muslim and I'd say more so like I
have it in like some dreams where
like I I'm afraid to maybe say that I'm
gonna do something like that but
in reality like
it just changes everything like when you
do say that you are a Muslim when you do
act
according to being a Muslim you know
like people who treat you differently
people see you differently and um
there's a different type of respect that
they give you
you know and like when they see that
you're actually about that I'll give you
guys a story Okay so
um I was with two friends
we were actually going to the shooting
range
and as we were in the car they started
making like some jokes and they started
making like Jew jokes because one of
them wasn't you
and he's not a Jew anymore I think he's
Christian and the other one I think he's
just agnostic like he believes in God
but he didn't he's not religious right
and
um the one that's you know he's agnostic
he was like going at it like making
these jokes and then he he said
something about Islam
and like I had to stop him were you
Muslim at the time I was oh so it was
after you reverted yeah I wasn't I had
to stop him I was like yo
well I think that's about as far as we
go with that you know like like leave it
like drop it and then he was like oh bro
like quit taking it so seriously I was
like listen
like that's that's religion you don't
play around with that you don't joke
around about that stuff and he's like
bro like he looked at me he's like
because I told him I was like don't
don't play around and
and he basically looked at me he's like
no like
I'm gonna say what I want and I look bro
I literally looked at I was like listen
if you're not going to respect a
religion
then respect me as a man when I tell you
not to say something like that like have
some respect and bro like instantly
he just stopped the other dude in the
car as well
he stopped and it wasn't like oh there
was this bad Vibe but it was more like
respect because I was able to express
that because I I'm 100 Muslim I'm not
Muslim 50 of the time like I'm 100 and
as a Muslim like you have to you have to
stand for your Dean you have to stand
for something unless you're gonna be
like
the uh the other people I won't even
mention them that they don't stand for
anything so they fall for anything you
know what I'm saying Allah honor people
that just about the knee roll over for
exactly approval you know what I mean
how many people have opportunities to
defend Islam but they don't they hear
islamophobic jokes or remarks and
they're just like I don't want to say
anything and put the spotlight on me bro
at the end of the day listen Allah
guides who he guides Allah misguides
what he guides it's not your job to
fight every battle and you know turn
every heart you can't it's not even in
you to begin with so you don't have to
come here and philosophically or
ideologically convince everyone that
Islam is true or try to rationally you
know justify your perspective or
anything that's what we're doing but if
you you know if you come across people
that come sideways like Angel's friend
and salafi's gonna be crazy like yo what
is on her doing in a car with a Jew and
an agnostic anyway bro hold on a stuck
for the love bro this is Haram
Haram but at the end of the day this is
what happened how you handled it is
actually I would say a commendable way
to handle it mashallah
and
what's that guy gonna do just as Maddie
said what is that guy gonna do next time
that he thinks about making a Muslim
joke around you it's a good thing he's
gonna think twice and over time he's
gonna think twice being with other
people and saying those things you know
it's rubbish bro
it's exactly bro
I'm gonna bless you for that sharing
that
Habibi bro
yeah zoom in on that bro
uh comment Down Below guys if you
actually think that if you didn't know
on who was Puerto Rican River to Islam
does he not just look like a Saudi or
Egyptian Sheikh just look at him bro
just look at this guy mashallah though
yeah let us know guys if you if he looks
like a Puerto Rican Reaver or actual
legit chef from emirati bro who knows
um yeah anything else you guys have of
the next question
um this is something I was talking to
with Rami before the the podcast and
it's it's the night prayer we talked a
little bit about in the beginning but
you know I talked to a lot of people
that have achieved a relative degree of
success in their own field whether it be
in Commerce or in family or status or
whatever you know and I always ask a lot
of these people you know what did you do
to get here and a lot of these people
they give me different answers but one
thing I commonly hear among the Muslim
folk is the hajjad making Dua during the
never misses as they say
you know I know we all know what it is
but for the people that don't know what
it is do you want to elaborate a bit
Yeah Yeah and correct me if I'm wrong
I'm pretty sure is when you sleep right
after a shot and you wake up at the
night prayer that's the night prayer
that's done that you specifically wake
up for yeah anything other than that is
just it's just yeah
um more specifically I believe in the
last third of the night is the best time
to pray to Allah descends in the last
tour of the night yeah yeah I know is it
physically or no I know yeah they're
gonna go at each other and they're gonna
be like
I'm gonna go attack each other no it's
physical no it's your cafe or mob today
or is it a way that befits his majesty
yes stop trying to use logic bro you
cough I have this one love but yes and
and he asked basically you know I'm
gonna paraphrase a little bit but like
basically who's there to [ __ ] that I
can answer their their eyes such thing
give them what they want subhanallah
beautiful man it's beautiful and so and
then the night time is like
it's the most peaceful yeah everyone's
asleep yeah yeah yeah I heard I heard
this one this one thing once someone I
asked the Sheikh I know who it was but
they asked you know why is the air so
pure at the time of Fajr and the Sheikh
said because the the Hypocrites aren't
awake for that time they Hypocrites
don't wake up at that time
it's tough stuff inshallah
yeah that being said so this is
basically what tajit is
um specifically making Dua and tahaja
taking your time with it have either of
you noticed any type of relevance or
different in your life oh yeah I
personally obviously have otherwise why
would I be trying to preach it but huge
difference but what have you guys
noticed specifically
well
the biggest thing that I will say
is that
there's this sense of uh peace
in your life like things could be going
completely sideways but it's like you're
just kind of like
everything's all good you're okay with
it yeah yeah versus like let's just say
you're just doing the five prayers maybe
even taking your time with the prayers
maybe even doing the swimming prayers
for pro is like the haju just really
gives you what you're looking for bro
the clarity the peace or understanding
the guidance
the acceptance Pro everything man like
again I'm not going into details but I'm
just saying it gives you that sense of
Peace like maybe you don't have
the means to like let's say you have a
you live in an apartment you don't have
the means to pay rent
it's like bro you you're oh you're good
brother you don't even it's not even
stressing you when you break the [ __ ]
bro like it's just it's another level
that you have to experience it in order
to know what I'm talking about yeah yeah
even last night bro literally last night
bro I found a lot I woke up this morning
and you know how I was I'm like I'm
gonna need to sleep all day I'm gonna
take a nap I don't know if I'm gonna
record that you know all this stuff
right we pray to hajjud we stayed up I
maybe slept a little bit so maybe like
half an hour an hour until Fajr we woke
up went to the message of the prayer
pressure came back so that's a little
bit more I thought I'd be dead I'm the
line
I'm good enough and that's just like
such a a blessing people think praying
night prayer you know are you gonna take
time away from sleeping you're gonna
ruin your schedule you know all this
stuff it's like
the the blessings that it gives you in
your life is unmatched it's honestly
there's a level of being on
self-improven where you're here like
tracking your sleep you know you're like
I can't disrupt my testosterone
synthesis bro I gotta get on my sleep
but it's like listen yeah HGH you know
uh memory consolidation you know memory
going from short term to long term all
this happens in like third fourth rounds
like well I'm talking like you're
sleeping four five six hours
continuously right brother I can't
disrupt that I gotta get my gains listen
trust me when I tell you this there are
times when logically you might think
like if I if I do this for the sake of
Allah it will inhibit me and Dunya or
it'll make me deficient in this one
Avenue
I saw how it works bro when you go all
in Islam is complete submission to Allah
right when you go all in bro I'm talking
all the things you were stressing about
you were fussing about just sort itself
out you don't even worry about that like
logically one might think if I take time
away from work and I pray I'll make less
money that's not how it works bro yeah
you you take time off from work you say
no to the money you pause the money you
come to Allah
and that Allah can trust you with more
because he not hooked on to the money
like like a Coke addict you know you
you're okay with detaching from the
Dunya those that I see that are
extremely successful today in the Dunya
are those that don't need they've
detached from it but those that are
always trying to count every dollar and
be stingy and bro they stay in that
situation bro and my heart goes out to
them because I feel what they're going
through I'm sympathetic but they don't
realize that it's because of what
they're doing and how attached they are
to the Dunya that they're not getting
if only people understood If Only They
knew you chased it didn't you
you never have the Dunya and you'll
never have the akhira yeah but if you
chase the Akira don't yell at your feet
exactly that's what it is
Mercy I think that's a good note to end
off on yes sure look at that being said
[Music]
um
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
foreign